phil mickelson joining us on the program
did you get to see any of that display
there Phil I didn't see you throwing
darts but I love the I love the
terminology it's very similar to some of
the things I like to do what are the
what are your terms that you used
taystee was one yeah I like it bombs
I love tasty little morsel III don't
know what course that's part of the fun
you know creating your own Burbage I
guess where are you right now I'm in my
yard I'm getting ready to go practice
and do practice by yourself I get the
most done when I practice by myself yes
I don't get interrupted and I find it I
find it almost kind of like a meditation
type thing to be alone practicing but do
you play golf by yourself would you go
out and play 18 by yourself I am playing
36 today and now my mom is in town doing
some work with some of his companies and
people here in San Diego so we're gonna
go play this morning I've got Tom
Pernice and another player kendo Dody
who's on the corn ferry tour so we've
got a nice little game this morning
I like that was there at any point a
moment where you thought do I give Tom
Brady a lesson when you realized how he
was struggling on the front nine though
tom is one of those guys that he kind of
just finds away and if you get in his
way and you give him too much thought it
will it will inhibit him from figuring
it out and he just kind of figured it
out if you look at the way obviously we
played awful the first six holes both of
us but after that we played really
really well but we played for under par
the last 12 holes now an alternate-shot
I thought I thought if we shot like 38
or 39 like a couple over that'd be
really good we shot two under so he
really stepped it up on the on the back
nine but he was I think he acted like we
do on the weekend that was the thing I
loved about Brady is it humanized him
here's the greatest but he's just like
us when he gets out there the common
mistakes that you make you grip it
your swing is a little quick there and
you can't hide because this is on TV
you're right and that's why I give he
and Peyton a lot of credit because
they're the best of what they do and you
go into the arena of something that
they're not as comfortable in and
they're not as confident and have not
worked on very much that I give them a
lot of credit for putting themselves out
there that's not an easy thing to do I
thought they did with a lot of Grayson
in comedy what was your favorite moment
in the room my favorite moment was gosh
I think when Brady made the tube when he
made a cut on 11 because that gave us a
chance and in Peyton Manning had hit an
iron shot in there to like eight feet
and we're Tiger cutting meat he's gonna
make that putt and so this was our
chance to pick one up had we not made
that after playing this whole like
beautifully and then walk away with a
tie that would have been very deflating
instead of gave us this energy that hey
we can do this we can make this comeback
and we almost did and that putt that he
made on 11 was my favorite moment I
think I was amazed when I shouldn't say
amazed with Tiger but man he looked
pretty good Phil yeah he did he flat-out
did he hit some some great shots and was
in play all the time and and played
really really well but that the guy that
like stepped up was Peyton I mean my
goodness he makes a natural - on the par
3 the first part three he makes another
he makes a net - on number eight and he
makes a net birdie on seven and that was
a many many almost pulls it on 16 for 25
million knocks it foot that wasn't an
easy shot Oh strong wind and and I just
I just thought he played remarkable I
was really impressed with him and I was
impressive the way my partner turned it
around to Peyton was pretty good
trash-talking though he's he's stealth
there Phil he's brilliant and the thing
about Peyton is that his delivery is in
a way that laughs with them he does if
he doesn't elicit a defensive response
and so it makes it very easy and fun to
be around him and to have everybody
laugh at what is
I just love his delivery I love the way
he he kind of talks to himself kind of
mumbles but it's in a kind of a Larry
David kind of comedic way talking to
Phil Mickelson the cabs look great if if
you could pass a rule that you could
wear shorts would you be in favor
wearing shorts on tour but a pretty
funny topic the last year year to happen
how does your wife deal with this
she's very attracted to it why did you
have the best cat you have two football
players in Tiger Woods you had the best
calves out of all of them Phil
[Laughter]
being an analyst golf analyst does that
interest you at all when this is all
said and done I don't know when it's all
said and done your turn in 50 and you
look like you're still hitting it the
way you did you know ten years ago I'm
having so much fun playing that I want
to continue to play and this is the best
shape I've been and this is a fast as I
swung the club in a long time this is
the best I feel the hardest I've a table
of practice and the most fun that I'm
having while playing golf and so I want
I want to play compete and play against
the best players and I'm excited to get
back out on tour I'm excited to go play
here alone you'll see where where I'm at
because I feel like I've had a good
really good last few months to get my
game back and be sharp and I'm excited
to play so I don't want to say that I
wouldn't enjoy doing that I Justin
Thomas did a phenom he did yeah he was
sneaky good he was really good and his
personality came out I think he
resonated with a lot of people I think
it was really a good thing for him where
people got to see how funny he is
insightful he is and and fun of you I
think he gained a lot of fans by by
showcasing his personality that it
doesn't you don't always see in a
regular telecast I thought he did a
really great job and added the perfect
amount of spice to the event so what I
enjoy doing that yes I I think I'd be I
think I would enjoy doing that but I
really want to play right is this a one
and done or can you see weathers you
know are you and Tiger done with this
you know maybe coupling with somebody
and then maybe it's other pros in
quarterbacks coming in we've had a lot
of calls last couple of days that people
want in and I think that there's a
there's an opportunity here to create a
competition that is also very
entertaining that showcases a lot of
personality but it's still very
competitive and I thought that there
were some things that worked this this
time around that can work again I
thought having no people on the Golf
Course was a big thing I thought that it
allowed more of an interaction between
players and the viewer at home had a
much more intimate feel I thought the
cameras in the golf carts for its huge
thing I thought the carts were a good
thing because it's sped up the time in
between shots
yeah and shot right away but the cameras
in there brought in you inside inside
the course inside the players thoughts
and I thought that was a really good
thing and the other thing that I thought
was interesting was how the rain added
an element we were very concerned about
getting it in we were concerned about
having poor weather but I thought the
rain and the tough conditions made it
interesting and that actually opens it
up to another opportunity of maybe
having an event like this in
not-so-great weather so I thought there
were some things that that could be done
again that can really be fun that we we
I don't know if so we got lucky or just
had all kind of clicked on Sunday but I
thought that it was a really good
mixture of competitiveness
insightfulness as well as entertainment
with no galleries it looks like perhaps
for the rest of the year would you be
willing to be miked up do you think
players would be willing to be miked up
during a regular tour stop or even a
major I I would be I mean I would be
open to the idea because of how it's
being received and some of the insight
and so forth but you don't always don't
have the the play between individuals so
like I had a partner and Tom
I could talk back and forth and maybe
we'd have some of that with the caddy
but having a partners is much more
intimate and you have much better
conversation so in a real competition
for on the PGA Tour competing for a
title you won't have that type of kind
of interaction fonti yeah well it won't
be the same but I think it would still
add something and I would consider it
yeah if you can pick another partner now
now that you're done with Brady who
would you pick well it's it's really
hard to top him because he is he he
really brought a lot to the table and he
just he is just fun guy to be around so
it's hard to top him because he has the
right amount of intensity and the right
amount of interaction and smack-talk
back I mean I don't I don't know it
would have to all kind of play together
and work together and and what the
storyline is and we'll maybe sit down
and see if there's something that might
be interesting to the public and try to
create something again but I really like
the way this worked out and I'm really
appreciative of the the players of Tiger
of Payton of Tom of us all coming
together to do something that was really
cool it's great to talk to you and once
again raising 20 million dollars oh by
the way no small you know gesture there
that was wonderful
do you have shorts on right now yeah
let's see the calves can we see the
calves like I'm just look just for the
ladies who are watching here I don't
know if I get my leg that high come on
this is good for my ratings here your
calves here alright okay here we go
here's oh wow wow that is that's that's
some eye candy right there that's eye
candy alright go throw some darts there
and great to talk to you once again well
done very enjoyable and appreciate your
time as always
Phil Mickelson there